موضوع غريب وملفت تصدر الصحف الاوروبيه
موضوعنا البعض او لنقل الكثير من هو صعب
البلع والتماشي معه الاتحاد الاوروبي يعطي
الدواء الاخضر لمزيد من الحشرات التي تدخل
قوائم الطعام والمنتجهات
الصراصير المنزليه منزوعه الدهن يرقات
الديدان قرار ياتي بعد اعتماد الهيئه
الاوروبيه لسلامه الاغذيه بغرض تعزيز
الانظمه الغذائيه المستدامه
بوضوح الى استخدام الحشرات في مكوناتها
فالاعتماد بشكل اكبر على بروتين الحشرات
يمكن ان يخفض من نسب الغازات الدفيئه
والاحتباس الحراري لكن المهمه الاصعب
اقناع الناس بتخلي عن ظهورهم وتغيير
نظرتهم اتجاهها قبول تناول تلك الانوا حيث
ثلاثه ارباع المستهلكين غير مستعدين
استبدال اللحوم بالحشرات وفقا لتقديرا عن
المنظمات المستهلك الاوروبيه وحاليا تنظر
المفوضيه في ثمانيه طلبات لحشرات اخرى قبل
الموافقه على اعتمادك غذاء
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]